- Hi everyone.
Thank so much for coming, I'm Steve Pitti,
I'm the professor of
History and American Studies
and director of the Center
for the Study of Race,
Indigeneity, and Transnational Migration
here at Yale, thank you everybody
for turning out for this
wonderful opportunity
to hear from one of my
very favorite scholars,
Professor Ana Minian
of Stanford University.
I wanna thank Nandi Cummings and others
at the RITM Center for helping to put this
event together and making
all of this possible.
Ana Minian is assistant
professor of history
at Stanford, she received her BA degree
from the University of Chicago
and then her masters
and her PhD, the latter
in 2012 from Yale's
American Studies program
here in New Haven, her dissertation
which is the basis for her tremendous book
from which she's speaking today
and which you can see
pictured on the screen
next to me, received in 2012,
the Ralph Henry Gabriel
Prize for, as the best
dissertation written in American Studies,
in the field of American
Studies in that year.
Ana, as you'll see today, is a top scholar
of US History and of Mexican History,
especially in the late 20th Century,
and to my mind, is the finest historian
of Mexican migration working today.
She's published in the
Journal American Quarterly
and the Journal of American History,
in places like the Washington
Post and elsewhere.
She's also made other
important media appearances
in recent months, talking about issues
related to Mexican migration and migration
in Mexico, her book, Undocumented Lives,
published just months ago
by Harvard University Press,
in 2018, explores the
late 20th Century history
of Mexican undocumented migration
to the United States, the growth
of migrant communities
in the United States
and by national efforts,
in the late 20th Century
to regulate the US/Mexico border.
Ana, in writing this history, relies upon
an incredible set of
sources, of primary sources.
Many of which, she's the first to use
as a scholar, she did
over 200 oral histories
to do this project, she worked with
Government archives, she captured
migrant correspondents letters
and also used privately
held organizational
records and personal collections,
pamphlets and unpublished ephemera,
and newspapers and magazines collected
in places like Washington DC, Chicago,
the San Francisco Bay area, Los Angeles,
Michoacán, Zacatecas and Mexico City.
What she crafted, is really the first
sustained history of transnational
Mexican migration from roughly,
the year 1965 to 1986, and what she does
in this book, Undocumented Lives,
should, I think, reset how we talk about
the recent histories of both Mexico
and the United States,
indeed of governments,
of every day people, of migrants
and of non-migrants, of what it means
to be a way journeyer, of what it means
to be a family member, a citizen,
a queer subject, and much, much more.
Now, in the Academy, people like me
aren't supposed to have favorites
or favorite books, but this book,
and this scholar, the book at least
belongs on the shortlist, the small shelf
I think of most important books
published on these subjects
and on other subjects,
it's one that's deserving
of all of our attention,
and many more people's attention
and to Ana's great
credit, she's written this
in engaging prose and lively prose
in ways that should
engage a popular audience
and deserve to find their
way to a popular audience.
So please join me on welcoming,
Ana Minian back to campus.
(audience applauds)
- Well, with that, I don't know
what else to say, I was blushing,
it was the nicest introduction
I've ever received.
It is a real honor to be
here to present my work
with the Center for the
Study of Race, Indigeneity,
and Transnational Migration,
when I was at Yale,
this Center did not exist
and it's really incredible
that it is here now.
I want to especially thank, Nandi Cummings
and Steve Pitti for organizing my visit.
This book started as Steve was saying,
as a dissertation, here at Yale,
and it might be the most exciting moment
of my career to come back in order
to talk about it as a book now, here.
Approximately 40% of all Mexicans
from the state of Zacatecas now reside
in the United States.
Similarly, one third of all of those
from the state of Guanajuato now live
north of the border, and slightly more
Michoacanos, those from
the state of Michoacan
now work in the fields of California,
Oregon and Illinois, then the number of
Michoacanos who still
reside in their home state.
Latinos have become the largest
minority group in the United States,
constituting approximately
18% of the population.
There are an estimated 11 million
undocumented migrants, half of them
from Mexico now residing here.
The sheer number of Mexicans who migrated
to the United States and their importance
in politics, economics, and daily
social relations means that their stories
have shaped both Mexican
and US national histories.
Yet few historians have paid attention
to the causes and effects
of Mexican migration
in Mexico, and even fewer, have examined
how this phenomenon affected life
in both countries, creating
strong transnational
relations between them, incorporating
these dimensions, changes
our understandings
of both migration and of US/Mexico
relations more broadly.
My book, Undocumented
Lives, the Untold Story
of Mexican Migration examines this history
in the post-war years, it does so
by using sources that come from
the National Archives of both countries.
By using migrants personal collections
which included sources
such as the love letters
that migrants sent to
their communities back home
and the records of their
meetings, and by using
over 250 oral history
interviews that I conducted
on both sides of the border, with people
who came from communities from the states
of Michoacán, Zacatecas
which I pointed out
at the beginning, which
were some of the states
of highest out migration.
Using these sources, I examine
how unauthorized Mexican migration
became an entrenched phenomenon
in the years between 1965 and 1986.
I used these two dates
as book ends to my book
because they mark important turning points
in the history of migration.
Up until 1964, Mexico
and the United States
had a bilateral program through which
Mexican workers could
come as guest workers
and work legally for
short periods of time.
In 1964, the United States unilaterally
ends this program, which was called
the Bracero program, as a result,
the following year in
1965, Mexican workers
who were accustomed to coming here
and working, find themselves that they can
no longer come to the
United States legally.
But their conditions in
Mexico haven't changed
and so they continued coming, they simply
do so without papers.
Still, their migration is,
for the most part, circular.
Workers come, work here
for a short periods
of time, return to Mexico, and then repeat
this process, this pattern
of circular migration
ended in 1986, when the US Congress passed
the Immigration Reform and Control Act.
One of the main clauses of this law
was border fortification, the Act allotted
a lot of money to increase the size
of the border patrol and
surveillance technologies
across the border, as it became harder
for people, for Mexicans to cross
the border without papers, they decided
to come and settle permanently,
because they could no longer continue
to risk going back and forth now that
the border was so much harder to cross.
The years between 1965 and 1986 were ones
in which many of the current dilemmas
around undocumented migration were born.
This period saw the unprecedented rise
of unauthorized Mexican migration.
Apprehensions by the Immigration
and Naturalization
Service, otherwise known
as the INS, rose from 55,000 in 1965
to over one and a half million by 1986.
This is over a 3000% overall increase.
This period also saw key shifts
in the government
policies of both countries
with regards to migration,
and perhaps more important,
it was during this period
that Mexican peoples
consciousness shifted
toward an acknowledgement
that their future depended
on undocumented migration.
Because of time constraints,
I will not be able
to touch on every aspect that I talk about
in my book, instead, I
will focus on talking about
the broad arguments that I make
through the question of welfare.
I do so because the question of welfare
alongside with ones of gender, sexuality
and geographical space, because welfare
is one of the main threads
that run throughout
the book, alongside those other threads.
Now focusing on welfare
today, I will discuss
two of the main points
that I make in my book.
First, I argue that during the 1970s,
working class men faced
exclusionary pressures
to leave both Mexico
and the United States.
Now, that migrants are excluded
from the United States
seems, especially nowadays,
almost intuitive, but that Mexicans
were excluded from Mexico,
is much more surprising.
It means that migrants
faced a double exclusion
from the two countries where they lived.
This double exclusion was enacted both
by the government officials of Mexico
and the United States as well
as by migrants own communities.
Let me explain this point a bit further.
In Mexico, the government's
top policy makers
concluded that because the nation
could no longer afford
to act as a welfare state
because the Mexican economy
was starting to decline,
it had to find a way
to reduce unemployment
and one of the ways to
do so was to encourage
people to emigrate, on the other side
of the border, in the United States,
migrants started to find themselves
accused of draining welfare and they were
regularly deported,
migrants own communities
started to reject migrants presence
in either Mexico or the United States
on a permanent basis, increasingly,
migrants found that they
could belong nowhere
that they could live on a permanent basis
neither in the United
States, nor in Mexico.
They started to claim that they were
from neither here nor there,
(speaks foreign language).
Now my second argument, is
that during this period,
migrants advanced their own visions
of where they belonged, by doing so,
they countered their double exclusion
from Mexico and the United States,
in particular, I focus on how they created
groups in Los Angeles, that provided
economic security for migrants
in the United States as
well as for Mexican citizens
who remained in Mexico.
By guaranteeing that those back home
had their basic needs satisfied, I argued,
these migrant organizations started to act
as a type of extra-territorial
welfare state.
Through this activism, migrants managed
to become central players in regional,
national and transnational politics.
Now to make these two arguments today,
I will first show how the US government
then the Mexican government, and then
Mexican communities, used ideas of welfare
to deny migrants the right to settle
permanently in any place,
I will then move on
to show how by creating
welfare organizations,
migrants managed to create their own
cartographies of belonging.
Let's start in the United States,
where one of the main rallying cries
against unauthorized Mexicans starting
in the 1970s, was that they were
draining the nation's welfare coffers.
During this decade of economic crisis,
the US economy saw the rapid rise
of unemployment and
inflation simultaneously.
The expansion of welfare came to be seen
as an urgent national problem
and people of color were often accused
for draining welfare.
Newspapers often blame the "black,
"promiscuous, Cadillac
driving welfare queen,"
for the expansion of welfare.
This has led historians to focus strictly
on the cultural associations between
black people and welfare abuse,
yet the majority of newspaper articles
that talked about the problems created
by Mexican migrants, also referred
to their use of public aid and services.
Articles came out with titles such as,
"illegal aliens here, called
public services burden,"
and "welfare system a
haven for illegal aliens."
Mexicans tried to
counter these stereotypes
by blaming US-born Mexican-Americans
for the existing associations between
Mexicans and welfare abuse, for instance,
Agapito Rodriguez, who
migrated from Zacatecas
held that everyone in
the migrant community
believed that it was US
born Mexican-Americans
who were abusing welfare,
among his friends,
he claimed, Mexican-Americans were seen,
"as lazy people, we,
migrants, would go to work,
"but those people generally did not work,
"but instead survived from welfare."
This commonly used
strategy of shunning other
marginalized groups did not
help undocumented migrants
who continued to be
associated with abusing
public welfare, these
associations were particularly
unsuitable because unauthorized migrants
were ineligible for public
welfare and few dared
to apply for aid legally,
at least six different
field studies published at the time
found that unauthorized Mexican migrants
rarely used public support,
such as unemployment
compensation, welfare
assistance or food stamps.
This meant that Mexican migrants
were simultaneously accused of draining
public resources and at the same time,
prevented from applying for welfare.
Still, one of the main
arguments hurting Congress
against undocumented
migrants, was of course,
that they drained welfare.
In 1976, those who wanted to limit
the number of Mexicans
in the United States,
had a clear victory with the passage
of the Western Hemisphere Act.
This Act established an annual quota
of twenty thousand immigrants per nation
from countries in the Western Hemisphere,
a clause that affected
Mexico in particular,
as it was the only country
with an immigration rate
much higher than twenty thousand per year.
The passage of the bill
was defended in part
through arguments such as those of
Senator Thurmond of South Carolina,
who argued that, "in many cases,
"these illegal entrants and their families
"soon become a welfare
burden on our society.
"Supported in one way or another
"by American taxpayers," arguments
that Mexican migrants drained welfare
did not simply affect
the marking of the border
through legislative means, they also
encouraged the INS to increase
the number of raids that it was conducting
in Latino communities.
In June 1973, Donald T. Williams,
then Acting Director of the INS, explained
the increasing number of raids,
by stating, "immigrants attend schools
"at taxpayers expense, they take jobs
"that normally would got to Americans,
"and many of them go on welfare
"and use other public social services."
So, notions of welfare,
played a significant role
in pushing migrants out
of the United States
by encouraging US officials to introduce
legislative changes to immigration law
and by encouraging them to conduct
more raids against undocumented workers.
Although Mexicans kept crossing the border
and living in the United States,
policy makers accused them of
being outsiders who drained welfare.
Now let me turn to the case of Mexico.
Like US officials, during the 1970s,
Mexican officials also started to reject
migrants presence in their country.
The Mexican government
had a very different
rhetoric on welfare than
did US policy makers.
After the Mexican
revolution, the ruling party,
The PRI, established
itself as the promoter
of the Mexican Welfare State.
But even though the government
legitimatized itself
through claims that it
was a welfare state,
it failed to ensure the economic wellbeing
of its citizens.
Up until the mid-1970s,
Mexican policy makers
had long considered that to achieve
a welfare state, and
accelerate economic growth,
they had to pursue
population growth policies.
In fact, since Mexico's independence,
Mexican officials had tried to increase
the number of people who
resided in the country
in order to accelerate the country's
economic development, now
in terms of migration,
what this meant of course, was encouraging
those who had already
migrated, those who were
already in the United
States to return to Mexico
while discouraging others who were
still in Mexico from going abroad.
In the mid-1970s, Mexico's top politicians
started to change their position.
In part, because of
the collapsing economy.
During these years, the balance of payment
ran a huge deficit and
consumer prices doubled.
Before leaving office in 1976,
President Luis Echeverría was forced
to devalue the Peso, ask for assistance
from the IMF, and accept
its austerity package.
Mexican officials debated how to solve
the nation's economic problems.
Should they continue to
expand the welfare system
even further, should they start to change
their position, ultimately, they concluded
that population growth was
no longer advantageous.
If anything, Mexico's population
had to be reduced, one way to do so
was by accepting and sometimes even
by encouraging citizens emigration
to the United States.
Now existing government archives
contain limited explicit evidence
in which policy makers openly acknowledge
changing their views on immigration
as a way of alleviating
Mexico's economic problems.
Speaking of such a
change, would have meant
recognizing that the PRI was giving up
on the revolution's welfare goals
of providing Mexicans with the means
of residing with humane living standards
in their country of birth.
It would have also meant acknowledging
that the Government rejected the presence
of some citizens in the national territory
and that officials had started to favor
their departure to a
country where they were
viewed primarily, as "illegal aliens."
Despite the paucity of
such explicit evidence,
the jumbled changes in state practices
that occurred between the mid-1960s
to the mid-1980s, elucidate politicians
changing positions, let me give you
a couple of examples that illustrate
how they went from discouraging
unauthorized migration to
viewing it as necessary.
First, from the mid-1940s
to the mid-1970s,
Mexican and US migratory officials
had coordinated mechanisms to repatriate
deportees deep into
the interior of Mexico.
These officials knew that if they released
the deportees near the border region,
these migrants would simply cross over
to Mexico the following day.
So the mechanism they introduced,
worked like this, when
immigration officials
in the United States caught
unauthorized migrants,
they would take them
to the US/Mexico border
and they would hand them
to Mexican officials
from the Mexican Department of Migration.
This Department of
Migration was then in charge
of taking the migrants
away from the border
and deep into the Mexican interior.
And here we can see,
officials from Mexico's
Departamento de Migración,
Department of Migration,
and a group of men that
has been apprehended
and is about to board on a train
to take them into the interior of Mexico.
Now, in the mid 1970's
when Mexican officials
started to look favorably on immigration,
they stopped attempting to take deportees
away from the border and
into the Mexican interior.
This change began in 1976.
When US officials wanted to sign
a two million dollar contract
with Mexican officials
to be able to send deportees by plane
into the Mexican interior,
the Mexican government
for the first time, refused
to give these companies
permission to work, the
government officials
claimed that the deportees had the
"constitutional right" to
stay in Northern Mexico
if they so desired, now let me point
that before this point,
those constitutional rights
didn't seem to matter.
Another example of
politicians changing position
is that by the mid-1970s,
they started to work
on defending the rights
of undocumented migrants
in the United States, such attempts
to protect Mexicans in the United States
are not mentioned in government documents
until after Mexico's top politicians
changed their position
with regard to immigration.
The migratory worker archives,
which are all the archives that document
the instances in which Consuls assisted
Mexican workers who lived
in the United States
as well as Mexican National Archives,
all indicate that the concern over
undocumented migrants rights did not begin
until the late 1970s,
when Mexican officials
had started to view immigration favorably.
On the contrary, existing
government documents
show how before the mid-1970s,
Mexican officials insisted that Mexicans
who migrated illegally, lost their right
to protection as a result of their
unauthorized migration, this strategy,
which they communicated to Mexican workers
comes out in the
correspondence that they sent
to workers, such as in the letters
that government officials
sent to Epifanio Quintín.
On September 30, 1968, Quintín's son
died from asphyxiation after his smugglers
left him in a hermetically
closed U-Haul truck.
For Quintín's family, the tragedy
was compounded by their poverty.
As Epifanio Quintín explained to
the Mexican Consul in San Antonio.
He could not support his wife
and his son's children with the five
daily pesos that he made
as an ice cream vendor.
Quintín requested that
the government allow
one of his other sons to
go to the United States
as a bracero.
Government officials
replied that they could not
allow Quintín's other sons to go
to the United States as braceros because
the Bracero Program had officially ended
but they then added
that they "considered it
"convenient to emphasize
that Quintín's sons
"not abandon their residence
without the existence
"of a legally authorized work contract,
"as they would other expose themselves
"to leaving the country
without the protection
"of the law and would run the risks
"to which those who break
such laws are exposed."
Before the mid-1970s, officials insisted
that migrants lost their
right to protection
as a result of their
unauthorized migration.
In contrast, by the mid-1970s,
government officials
repeatedly informed migrants
of their aims to defend them.
In 1978, for instance, the government
publicly announced the
opening of the first office
for the protection of
undocumented workers,
living in the United States.
This new interest in the
human rights of Mexicans
who resided in the United States,
is particularly surprising
given the government's
blatant disregard for
the rights of citizens
who still resided in Mexico.
As Human Rights Watch noted,
"since the late 1960s,
"and early 1970s, an array of abuses
"have become an institutionalized part
"of Mexican society, including killings,
"torture and abuses against
independent unions."
Officials interest in the human rights
of citizens in the United Sates,
and their concurrent
lack of concern for them
while in Mexico, was
related to their belief
that many Mexican citizens ought to live
north of the border.
After Mexican officials
changed their views
regarding migration, they
also openly attempted
to convince the United States, to allow
undocumented migrants to reside there.
They even did so by
fanning out Cold War fears.
For example, in 1979, Mexico's Secretary
of Foreign Relations, Jorge Castañeda,
asserted that the United States
was not giving Mexico
special consideration
when it came to immigration.
Given that the United
States was not giving
Mexico the special consideration,
Castañeda said Mexico would start looking
to Latin America as well as to, "Europe,
"Japan, The Socialist countries."
in this not-so-veiled threat,
he impressed upon the United States
how important immigration was
for Mexico's government.
Before I continue, up to now
I have been arguing that during the 1970s
ideas of welfare pushed forward
the view that Mexicans did not belong
in the United States, these notions
encouraged US Government officials
to deport more Mexicans and made it harder
for Mexican migrants to
enter the United States.
During this same decade,
Mexican authorities themselves
started to reject the presence of migrants
in Mexico, while the Mexican government
had previously attempted
to act as a welfare state
and continued to portray itself as such,
by the mid-1970s, Mexican officials
believed that the way
forward was to encourage
working class citizens
to live in a country
that viewed them as "illegals."
Now that I have examined how migrants
experienced a double exclusion from Mexico
and the United States,
because of the pressures
enacted by both governments, let me turn
to the pressures migrants faced
from their own communities.
At the local level, migrants families
and friends also started to deny them
the ability to reside permanently
in either country.
Because the Mexican
government failed to act
as a true welfare state on which people
could rely in time of need, families
and communities started to pressure
married men to head north to support them.
Antonio Córdova, from
the town of Tzintzuntzan
Michoacán, recalls that
before he started migrating
he went to meet with government officials,
to ask them for credit to buy oxen.
According to Córdova, if he had received
this credit and had been able to buy oxen,
he would have been able
to avoid going north,
which he did not want
to do, but he recalls
that, these officials just said go,
I'll examine your case
on this date or that date
but they never did anything.
Without prospects for
jobs and nowhere to turn
for help, Córdova knew that
he would have to migrate.
His own family members insisted
that he go to the United
States to support them.
Now, from this example, you might have
already picked up that
unauthorized migration
and the pressures people felt to migrate
had a profound gender dimension.
These gender dynamics often had
unexpected affects, in
Mexican communities,
Mexican men bore the pressures to migrate
to support their families.
Although some women also migrated
to work, during the years between 1965
and 1986, it was mostly men who migrated
and the community pressure to do so
fell almost strictly on them.
After all, it was extremely expensive
for whole families to go north.
In part, because of smugglers fees.
Divisions of labor within the family
led people to believe that men are
to go north for work in the United States
while women remained at home,
taking care of the children.
As Maria Reyes from
Nochistlán, Zacatecas recalls.
"I thought about migrating, but I couldn't
"because of my many children.
"I was tired of being
alone while my husband
"was in the United States.
"I would tell him, take me with you
"and he would say, how
can I take you with me.
"First, where would we
stay, we're too many.
"Second, how can I take you, when it's
"so hard to cross over," like most women,
Reyes never considered asking her husband
to look after their
children while she migrated
and remitted money for the family.
Women were also discouraged from migrating
because of sexual violence at the border.
Horrifying stories of the dangers
that women faced circulated throughout
Mexican towns, discouraging many women
from attempting their luck in El Norte.
For example, in the town of
Ruiz Cortinez, Michoacán,
women warned each other about the dangers
of going to the United
States by telling the story
of one particular villager, whose smuggler
had sexually abused her,
and according to them,
her life had since been ruined.
While women were discouraged from heading
to the United States, men
felt pressured to do so.
Significantly, it was
women, in their roles
as wives and mothers,
who were the main people
who pushed men to migrate.
For instance, Eloisa Garza,
from Nochistlán, Zacatecas
recalls that like many women, she insisted
that her husband migrate to provide
for their family's welfare,
"because he had to go
"to make money to support
us, he had to work
"to be able to provide us with food,
"because in Mexico, life is very hard."
Her husband's parents and friends
also pushed him to go.
The staggering rates of male migration
left many men feeling inadequate
if they did not go to United States
to provide for their families.
Migrating, to ensure
their family's welfare
became a way to establish one's manhood.
Rafael Ruano recalls
that like many other men,
he migrated with three friends,
who pressured each other
into taking the journey.
Had Ruano not migrated, he would have felt
cowardly, he says, and probably,
would have been ridiculed.
Community pressure changed the way
many men felt about the
space of their home town.
In oral history interviews, they regularly
describe the pressures
they faced to head north
as if their home towns were shrinking
around them and squeezing them out.
As Ricardo Perez explained,
"everyone expected
"me to leave and come back with money.
"I felt like I couldn't remain in town
"without going to the United States."
But once in the United States,
men felt that their loved
ones, the very people
who had pressured them to go north
in the first place, now prevented them
from residing there permanently.
Once men were abroad, their wives,
children and parents, regularly
pressured them to return home.
Everado Camacho for instance, recalls
that his wife and daughter
constantly reproached him
for leaving them alone too much
during his stays abroad.
From the United States,
men would receive letters
from their families begging them
to return home soon.
Up to now, I have shown how men
came to see their communities
in the United States
as places where they could
only reside in temporarily.
And their hometowns as spaces that shrunk
around them, and squeezed them out.
It is important to note, however,
that women also saw their
sense of space diminished
as a result of men's migration.
After going to the United States,
men started to fear that their wives,
who remained in Mexico,
would cheat on them
and so started to prohibit them
from socializing outside the home.
According to Annabel Tran, who lived in
Santa Fe de la Laguna, Michoacán,
"villagers often gossiped about women
"who socialized outdoors, and they claimed
"that they were being unfaithful
"to their husbands," because rumors
of infidelities often reached El Norte,
women started to fear that if they went
outside of their homes too much
and rumor spread that they were cheating
on their husbands, the men would stop
sending them money, as such,
many women started to avoid going outside
as much as possible.
Migration is often associated with a sense
of cosmopolitanism and an opening
of people's words, but when it came
to unauthorized Mexican migration,
both men and women, saw
their sense of space
diminished in significant ways,
as a result of men's migration.
Let me summarize what I have been saying
up till now about the
pressures migrants experienced
on both sides of the border.
Migrants faced a double exclusion
that prevented them from residing
in Mexico, and the United States.
This exclusion was enforced
by government officials
from both countries as well as
by their own families and friends.
Mexico's leaders used migrants
as economically superfluous and favored
their departures from Mexico.
US officials, came to consider migrants
as draining welfare resources,
and regularly deported them
from the United States.
Migrants own communities
rejected their presence
in either country by holding
that their own welfare depended on
migrants remittances and return visits.
Now, in this context, migrants sought
to exert their local,
regional, and national
belonging by creating their
own welfare organizations.
To demonstrate this, I'm going to focus
on the activism of Mexican
nationals in Los Angeles.
One of the main migrant
institutions that worked
to help other migrants during these years,
was the Comité de Beneficencia Mexicana,
often referred to in English, as
the Mexican Welfare Committee.
When one examines the
applications for relief
that the Comité received, a paradox
regarding welfare soon becomes clear.
As we have seen, US
anti-immigrant practices
were often influenced by the rhetoric
that Mexicans abused welfare.
But these exclusionary
practices themselves
were often responsible
for driving migrants
into seeking aid, for example,
in 1970, immigration officials detained
24 year Ubaldo Rosas, to deport him back
to Mazatlán, Sinaloa.
On the train ride south, the officers
beat him up and
confiscated his belongings.
Fearing for his safety, Rosas jumped
from the train, but he miscalculated
the distance and fell on the rails.
The train severed both
legs and two fingers
from his left hand, Rosas came to require
a wheelchair, he couldn't afford
to buy it himself, so he solicited aid.
But not from US state resources,
but from the Comité de
Beneficencia Mexicana.
Border enforcement led Rosas to seek
welfare aid, yet rather than resorting
to US state resources, Rosas depended
on the support of other migrants.
The Comité provided him
with the financial support
and wheelchair he needed.
The Comité became so influential
that Mexican consuls and even the LAPD
sent Mexican nationals to seek aid
from this organization, in other words,
migrants became central players
in providing each other with their
basic necessities in the United States.
The Comité raised money primarily by
renting out a building it owned
called The Casa del Mexicano,
and this is a picture of how
The Casa del Mexicano looked.
By the mid 1970s, the main groups
that rented out Le Casa,
were clubes sociales,
often known by their contemporary term
of hometown associations.
These clubs worked to send funds
across the border to develop
their communities in Mexico.
As a result they acted very differently
from the mutual aid societies
that most historians have analyzed,
which worked to support migrants
within the United States.
Instead, clubes sociales, I argue,
acted as a type of
extraterritorial welfare state.
From the United States, clubs took on
the role of the Mexican government
and sought to ensure the
welfare of all Mexicans.
Activists themselves
have this interpretation.
In his unpublished
memoirs, Raúl Villarreal
who was one of the main club activists,
recalls that history is,
"one of a simple dishwasher
"from a Los Angeles
restaurant, who by working
"in clubes sociales, ended up helping
"the people of Mexico more
than the government itself."
These groups started as
very small organizations.
In 1962, a group of migrants who
was living in Los Angeles but who came
from the small Mexico rancho
of Guadalupe Victoria,
which is located in
the state of Zacatecas,
decided to start raising funds
to send money back home, and here you have
a list of the first members
of this organization.
As you can see, it's not very big,
there's very few members,
they're each donating a
dollar each at a time.
This was a very small scale operation
to begin with, however, migrants
from other communities in Mexico
soon followed the example
of the Clubes Social
Guadalupe Victoria, and by the mid-1970s,
a large community developed in Los Angeles
around the idea of sending aid to Mexico.
The club culture that took shape
in Le Casa del Mexicano, revolved around
dances that happened every weekend
and which had approximately 350 attendees.
Parties began at 8PM and ended at 2AM.
As they roared on, people would laugh,
dance and converse until the music ended.
Once the party's finished, migrants left
with a renewed sense of
community and belonging.
The hosting club, with a profit
of approximately $600.
Club members sent the money they collected
to local agents in
Mexico who were in charge
of managing the funds, for example,
the Clubes Social de Guadalupe Victoria,
remitted the money migrants fund raised
to club agents residing in the rancho.
These agents then distributed it
to the elderly on a weekly basis.
As the club developed,
it started to take on
bigger and bigger projects.
By 1987, the club had
also paved the ranchos
main street, fenced its school, set up
electric power lines, wait,
brought portable water
and built a clinic, and this is a picture
of how the clinic looks today.
In others words, migrants
in the United States
raised money and club
representatives in Mexico
ensured that it was
appropriately distributed.
Together, they formed a welfare system
that guaranteed that the ranchos'
basic necessities were met.
Migrants felt their families and friends
prevented them from settling in either
their hometowns or in
their new communities,
but through their club activism,
migrants managed to become central figures
in both these locales.
From the United States, migrants changed
the built environment
and living conditions
in Mexico, when people
walked through paved streets,
attended clinics, or even flipped on
and turned their light switches,
they had to think about
migrants' contributions.
The very meaning of hometown
became imbued with migration.
Similarly, by creating long-lasting spaces
where they could gather
in the United States,
migrants managed to build a community
north of the border,
despite the impermanence
of their individual stays there.
Club members realized
that they were taking on
responsibilities that were traditionally
assumed by the state, but they argued
that if they did not,
the Mexican government
would not either, as
Gregorio Casillas explained,
"the government wasn't
interested, for example,
"it's the government's
obligation to provide
"what the community needs,
like electric lights,
"clinics, schools, but unfortunately
"they didn't do it, so
we had to intervene."
From the 1960s to the mid-1970s,
the Mexican government ignored clubs.
Finally, in 1986, Zacatecas'
Governor Genaro Borrego,
realized that given the huge impact
that migrants had on the state,
he could not continue to
ignore club activities.
That year, he agreed to develop a program
by which the state government would match
every dollar that migrant organizations
sent to Zacatecas for the
betterment of their communities.
This agreement marked the first time
that migrants were granted
official recognition
by a state government.
In 1999, the Mexican Government began
the Programa Tres Por Uno, three for one,
by which Federal, Municipal,
and State governments
all give a dollar for every dollars
club send for the
betterment of communities.
In 1986, the year that
Borrego got involved
with club activities, the US Congress
passed the Immigration
Reform and Control Act
which further fortified
the US/Mexico border.
By then, however, undocumented migration
had already become a
self-perpetuating phenomemon.
Migrants such as those involved in clubs
had learned that through their migration,
they could at least acquire partial,
national and local belonging in
the multiple spaces in which they lived.
Crossing the border became
increasingly dangerous
after 1986, men started refraining
from circular migration and instead,
encouraged their whole families
to cross the border once
and relocate permanently
in the United States.
They did not dare head back to Mexico
for fear that they would not be able
to cross back north again.
Now, rather than feeling pushed
out off all the places
in which they lived,
and having a sense of themselves
as being from neither here nor there,
migrants now started to feel entrapped
in the United States,
which they came to refer to
as la jaula de oro, or the golden cage.
My talk has focused on how, in the years
between 1965 and 1986, migrants faced
a double exclusion from
Mexico and the United States,
but also they managed to assert
their own cartographies of belonging
through their activism.
Among other issues, my book also examines
how queer men were the only ones
who could refrain from migrating.
It examines the other
types of transnational
activism, in which migrants engaged,
and then analyzes the
broader economic developments
that shape the policies of both countries.
As such, I offer a
transnational perspective
of the history of Mexican migration
and the growth of Latino communities.
As a conclusion to
today's talk, let me point
some of the ways in which the history
I just recounted sheds light
on the present situation
facing undocumented
Mexicans in the United States.
A growing number of US
citizen are once again
resorting to 1970s
stereotypes that portray
Mexicans as draining welfare and calling
for their deportation.
Mexican government officials continue
to view with favor, the departure
of Mexican citizens to the United States
and even now, have not implemented systems
to incorporate those
who are being deported
into Mexico's economy.
US politicians continue to ignore
how border fortification in fact increased
the number of people residing
in the United States.
While before 1986, it was primarily men
who migrated and they did
so in a circular fashion,
after the border became fortified in 1986,
entire families migrated
and settled permanently
north of the border.
But this history shows how, by uniting
migrants can improve their conditions
and achieve local,
national, and transnational
recognition and against all odds.
After all, the years between the 1960s
and the 1980s are ones which both Mexican
and US historians described as ones
that saw a rapid political shift
from the left to the right, a decline
in leftist activism, and the growing
demonization of the welfare state.
Still, during these years, unauthorized
Mexican workers managed
to create their own
cross-border welfare institutions,
and to fight for their
needs in both countries.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
Thanks everyone, and so now I would love
to take some questions,
thoughts about the talk,
about the book if you read it.
- [Steve] I'm gonna close the door.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Thank you very much
for your presentation, it was wonderful.
I really look forward
to reading your book,
I've worked on Mexican history.
I'm writing my dissertation right now
about Cancun and there's a problem there
with migration, bringing people
from other parts of Mexico,
(coughing drowns out speaker)
so I'm wondering, maybe you address this
in the book, but you could talk more about
the Mexican dimensions of the story.
Why is Zacatecas and
Michoacán in particular
what was going on there,
with their political
economies during this century?
- That was forcing people to migrate?
So these were historically
areas of high out migration.
Their agricultural
communities with high levels
of drought, so whenever there's a drought,
people have to migrate,
there's very little options.
They're also communities where during this
and starting in the 1940s,
the Mexican government
started to implement what's known as
the Green Revolution, where it introduced
new technologies to modernize
Mexican agriculture,
such as the use of new fertilizers
or irrigation, but it
didn't introduce them
in every single area, so
areas that were not modernized
for example, now had to compete,
with more modernized areas, which was
basically impossible, and not only that,
but the areas that were being modernized
often needed fewer workers, so that also
left workers without a job,
which encouraged them to migrate,
especially because they
had also been doing that.
Alongside that, from 1942 to 1964,
Mexico and the United States
had this program that I talked about,
the Bracero Program, which was bilateral
guest worker program for
which Mexican workers
could come and work for
short periods of time.
Much of the recruiting for that program
happened in those states, in
the central plateau region.
Now, once you have people
starting to go to United States,
a culture of migrationists develop.
People already know how
the uNited States work,
they learn some English,
they know where to go,
it makes it much easier for them
to continue going to the
United States afterwards,
so in some ways, that
helped to promote migration
in following years as well,
so for all these reasons, those states
are the states that were seeing
highest out migration in the years
between 1965 and 1986 and earlier as well.
And later, it starts to
diversify to other parts
of the country, but what's interesting,
is that most people are not thinking
about the south, which is a migration
that starts later, but
they're always surprised
that it's not people from Northern Mexico
that were migrating more.
I mean part of the reason that happens
is because Mexico was investing much money
in Northern Mexico in a way that it wasn't
investing in the central plateau region,
in this western states.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
- [Lady] When the wives.
- Can I give you the mic?
- Oh sure.
- [Lady] When the husbands of the wives
that left and the wives were getting
or more that the husbands were getting
concerned about the behavior of the wives
did this sort of intensify an already
misogynistic culture or
how did that shift if any?
- We often have these stereotypes
about Mexican machismo and it's every easy
to reproduce them, and part of what
I'm trying to do here is say,
there's machismo in some
way, it's conditional
to the structures that
occur, and migration
was one of the structures
that was occurring,
so yes, of course, there were some men
who were already telling
women not to go outside
and stuff, but their
fear, their insecurities
just increased so much,
they were like we're away,
what are our wives
doing, let's control them
in a way that beforehand, they didn't have
so much insecurity, because
they were always around,
they were seeing what was happening.
So their insecurities definitely increased
when they were in the United States,
and so they started to increase
their control over women,
now the way they did it
was not just through them, it was through
this whole social world that existed
of women in particular, who controlled
each others' movements, they controlled it
through gossip and they controlled it
because women often lived with their
parents-in-laws, so their parents-in-laws
would not allow their daughters-in-laws
to go outside, so it was a very much
controlling situation.
When men lived in Mexico,
they were the ones
in control, they didn't have to rely
on their parents-in-law, and often,
women experienced much more liberty
they claimed before men started to migrate
in such high numbers, and I actually think
that what thinking about this does,
is it disrupts the notion that Mexicans
are always machismo, and
show how the structures
really affect gender constructs.
- [Lady] Thank you for clarifying.
- [Man] Thanks so much for the talk
and I really enjoyed reading your book
and was particularly interested
in the appendix section
about doing oral history with queer folks
and thinking about queer migration
and I wonder if you could
talk a little bit more
about that aspect of the project
and how you approached
that, why that's of interest
and how that fits into the
story that you're telling.
- Yeah, so this project
started originally,
part of what I was looking at, I was
I was going around
Mexico and I noticed that
in many areas of Mexico,
there are a lot of areas
that had a lot of women,
had a lot of elderly people
a lot of men had already migrated,
but there was a lot of queer men
and I was like why is there such
a high proportion of queer men?
Why are queer men not migrating?
So at first, it did not start as
an oral history project per se,
but simply as an observation and then
as I went about it, first it was the idea
of how do I go about meeting people?
And it actually proved much easier
than I expected it to.
I went to churches, churches was one
of the main places where I met people
and although we think of Catholic Priests
as being homophobic,
actually in these towns,
everyone was okay with who was gay,
who was not, it'd be like, oh yeah,
Juanito, Perdito, you know, and they would
introduce me to the, and I was like,
(speaks foreign language)
if you wanna talk to me, and actually,
they would talk to me
and they would be like
they were fine talking about it,
and everyone else in town knew who was gay
so it was actually, it facilitated it
and in larger towns, where not everybody
knows each other so much,
the people who did know
everyone I found out, was taxi drivers.
Taxi drivers because they circulate
through town all the
time because they talk
they know everybody, and so I would just
hop on a cab and be like, and you know,
sometimes I had to play oh,
I'm fairly gender queer looking
and so I'd like play this,
oh, and so I'd arrive
to a group of men and I'd be like, hi,
I'm looking for gay men,
who of you could take me
and it was a group of taxi stands,
and I was like who could take me,
and they were like oh, he's gay,
oh no, he's gay, and I was like ha ha,
like it was the funniest thing
and then finally someone was like,
sure I'll drive you around
and I'll introduce you
to people, so as long as I was willing
to take their little
jokes and laugh with them
and in the end they introduced me
and they were, it's not
like they were homophobic
in the sense that they were laughing
at being queer as if that
was something to laugh at
but also they were really close friends
with the queer men and treated them
with respect, so I would
just talk to people
and I found it really strange how
originally, I found it really strange
how people were really open about it
and how priests were, later, I realized
I started looking at more manuscripts
and more archival manuscripts
and I realized that this had been part
of these communities for a very long time,
that this wasn't necessarily new.
And that gay men actually had a lot
of power in these
communities because as I say
in the book, they were able to take jobs
that were very highly paid, so women,
for example, were
florists, but stereotypes
would say that gay men
would be better florists
so they made a lot more money,
which placed them in very
economically privileged
situations, which in turn, gave them
a lot of power in their community.
So that also gave them some respect.
So people were willing to talk about it.
- [Lady] Thank you also for this,
this was absolutely fabulous.
Sort of going along with Adam's question,
it sounds like you had a really rich
and diverse source space
and I would love to hear
about the process of
going through everything
you found and being able to craft this,
what other projects you think
you could and will create
out of all this information
and how you chose to
privilege what information.
- Yeah, that's a really great question.
So I was interested in two different
sets of questions, one
is what was happening
at the Government level in
Mexico and the United States
and one was what was happening to people.
That's how it first stated,
so it was really easy
to separate the chapters, I was like,
okay these are the archives
of the Mexican Government
these are the archives,
and that's how the book
is written and it comes at a cost.
Another way that I could have written it
is in a much more
integrated way of how people
experienced government
policies, which I think
might have been more productive,
so it did come with a cost,
and that's another way
in which I could have written it.
Your other question, and oh and then,
what I did was I started incorporating
other dynamics that I
wanted, so for example,
activists and so I have
a chapter on activism
and often, things jumped
around, I think the stuff on
La Casa del Mexicano was originally
in chapter four, then
it came to chapter two
then it returned to four
and now it's in two again
so it really did change
and there's many ways
to write it, but I was trying to form
a narrative that was easy to understand
for people that showed
all the complexities
but that was also readable.
- [Lady] Thank you Ana
for a fascinating talk
and a very informed breaking book,
and I really appreciate how you complicate
a history of Mexican migration by
centering both the roles
of the Mexican government
and the US government and I'm intrigued
by your argument about how Mexicans
are displaced from both
Mexico and the United States
but also from the local communities
and your picture of la Casa del Mexicano,
made me realize that also
while they're being displaced
they find ways to create their own home
by titling it la Casa del Mexicano,
the home of the Mexican in this country
that isn't ours, so that's
mostly an observation
so thank you for connecting those points
that have not always been in the forefront
of how I understand Mexican migration,
but my question is about the role of women
who stayed in Mexico, so while men
were the main ones who
emigrated and were sending
money back, what was the
role of Mexican women
did they have any say,
or any leadership roles
in organizing how the
Money sent was being used
to maybe do the churches, or the clinics
or other services or were
they not involved at all?
- So, unfortunately, most women were not
involved at all to begin with because
a lot of the money that was being sent,
in terms of remittances, was being sent
to parents and then the parents-in-law
would distribute it to
the family accordingly
so they weren't in charge of that money
but what did happen
was that in Los Angeles
there is this beauty pageant
that is very very important
Señorita Mexico de Los Angeles.
It's a huge pageant, the person who wins
has a lot of power, and one year,
this one women, María Elena Serrano,
who's this lady over there, won
Señorita México de Los
Angeles, and she was also
extremely charismatic and the leaders
of clubes sociales realized
that she could help them
raise a lot of money, so
they made her president,
not just of one club, but of
the whole federation of
clubs, and at that point
she tried to change the position of women
within the clubs, now it wasn't much
because few women were
migrating, women were staying
primarily in Mexico, but for those women
she did change it for
a short period of time.
She didn't have much
success, but for a short
period of time, she did
incorporate more women.
As I showed there, part of what clubs
were also doing, for
example, was bringing people
such as Ramirez, who's okay,
she's called La Valentina,
she's like this women in
the Mexican revolution
who is known for her gender queerness
and they brought her and she came,
dressed In male garb in her full
so they were, in some
ways, working with queer
gender presentations and
changing gender norms
in that way, but in terms of the money
that was sent, it was men
and the agent in Mexico
who were in charge of the money
were primarily men, after 1986,
women do start taking
some positions of power
in local communities,
but what happens often
is that men are in charge of retuning home
to be, so for political positions,
of the ejido for example,
which are the communal lands,
who's going to rule the
ejido if all the men go?
You'd expect it to be women, but actually,
what starts to develop in many communities
is that they force a particular man
to return to be in charge of working
in the ejido, so women don't acquire
a lot of political power
in many communities.
In some they start acquiring more power
particularly in the state Zacatecas.
- [Lady] Thank you.
- [Woman] Hi, can you discuss the role
of children in your book and what impact
moving or not moving and staying in Mexico
had and the role of mixed
status families in your book.
- Well, there were few
mixed status families
because for the most part, children
were staying in mexico with their mothers
while the men were migrating,
so mixed status in the sense of more like
transnational, more like split.
Now we think of split families
when someone's deported
but back then the splitness primarily came
because the men was migrating,
so you talk to all these children
who say I grew up without
a father, I saw him
coming and going, but he wasn't there.
For example, I talked
about this guy Camacho
and he talked to his daughter Karen
and she says, I really resented him.
I didn't understand why he was going,
she was just a kid and tons of kids
describe the same thing.
Now, boys, describe
something very different
which is that they grew up knowing
that they would have to
come to the United States.
Now after 1986, of course, children
start growing up here,
children who would have
stayed in Mexico are now being brought
to the United States, so when we think
about people like Dreamers, right,
who are being sad, oh like the dreamers,
actually without IRCA,
without the fortification
of the border, those children would have
probably stayed in Mexico.
And it's this law that made it harder
for people to cross
the border and continue
to engage in circular migration
that led children to grow
up in the United States.
- [Steve] A segue to the
question I wanna ask Ana,
could you just give us a little sense
of the material you offer regarding
struggles for human rights on the US side
of the border in places like Arizona
and Texas, I'm thinking in particular
about the work that you did
on the Plyler v. Doe case
which does get to questions around kids
and the status of kids, the rights of kids
and the involvement of parents
in those struggles in particular.
But you also have some wonderful material
in the book related to labor rights,
for migrants in Arizona and I wonder
as we think about these questions
about wellbeing, if you
might just present us
at least briefly, with some
of your findings there.
- Yeah, so some children did migrate
and part of the struggle
that started happening
in Texas was that the Texas legislature
decided that school districts in Texas
could decide whether to
allow undocumented migrants
whether to start charging
them or whether not
to allow them at all, or whether just to
continue welcoming them, so every district
could do whatever they wanted.
And there's one district in Texas, Tyler,
where the principal
decided that he was going
to start charging admission, $1000
for every undocumented migrant.
Now, the kids could not pay that,
the parents could not pay that,
so ultimately, a group of parents
whose children were undocumented
decided to get together,
they went for help
everywhere they could, they couldn't find
a lot of help originally, finally,
a church member sent them to MALDEF
and lawyers from MALDEF,
which was a very important
Mexican-American organization,
took on their case.
And you know, they built a case
that ultimately was called Plyler V Doe,
Doe because of course, the children
couldn't use their name,
right, that would have been
a form, it would have been very easy
to retaliate against their families
in the small town of Tyler,
and Plyler because that was the name
of the Superintendent of the school.
And what was determined,
and you know MALDEF
put this very important legal brief
and they finally made
it to the supreme Court
and they won.
And the judges said yes,
undocumented children
can attend school, but they can only
but the reason why they
were determining this
is because it "wasn't
the fault of their own."
What this language does
is that it portrays
undocumented children as innocent
and undocumented adults as guilty,
without realizing the complex reasons
why undocumented adults are coming.
Now we don't have to fight for children
to go to school, we still
have to fight for them
to get into college for
free, to get the same amount
of grants and benefits to be able
to attend college, but we
don't have to fight that
for public schools and we
because of Plyler V Doe, but part of what
this law also does is that it criminalized
that it encouraged the
language that criminalizes
unauthorized adults, but this was
a very important struggle.
There were other legal struggles
that came about, one
of the ones that Steve
was mentioning was in Arizona.
At the time, most migrants were not going
to Arizona, they were going to California.
70% of all migrants were going to Cal,
I'm from Stanford, so I
always say they're coming here
they coming to California, they're going
to California, but some were going
to Arizona, especially from states
in Mexico with lower out migrations
so one of the most important states
where they were going to Arizona
was the Guerrero, which
at the time didn't have
such a high rate of migration.
But every year, every season,
seasonal workers would come, go to Arizona
and work there, now, working in Arizona
the jobs that, there were two jobs
that existed for farm workers;
working in the onion fields,
and working in the groves
in the citrus fields.
The onions paid much better, and it was
much easier work, but
undocumented migrants
could not do it, partially,
because immigration officials
were always circulating
throughout Arizona,
throughout this area, near Phoenix,
and they would see undocumented migrants
in the onion fields, but the groves
had so much foliage that they could hide
within them, so undocumented migrants
lived in the groves, they
never left the groves
they always lived there, they lived
in cardboard boxes or on top of branches
when there were sneaks to avoid them,
they drank water that had fertilizer
because that was what was available,
the living and working conditions
were absolutely dreadful.
So one undocumented migrant decided
that he wanted to organize these workers,
he had Joined the United Farm Workers,
the United Farm Workers at the time
did not support the United Farm Workers
are César Chávez's
movement, which at the time
was not, this is 1977, at the time
it was very conflicted
about whether to support
undocumented immigrants or not,
before then it had been very much opposed
to undocumented migrants, so there's one
organizer, Lupe Sanchez, splits away
from the United Farm Workers, and decides
that he is going to organize these workers
in Arizona, in the citrus groves
and the way he does it, is he realizes
he can't go into the groves, these
are private properties, the workers
aren't coming out, so
what is he going to do?
So what he does is he goes to Mexico
and organizes workers in Mexico itself
and he can do so because every season
people from the same communities in Mexico
would come to those fields in Arizona,
so circular migration is a way
which connects two very different places
and allows them to organize a population
that otherwise would
have been unorganizable.
And not only that, but by being in Mexico,
you were asking about
women, he meets their wives,
he meets the priests, the priests talks
to the men as well,
everyone convinces the men
that it's indispensable
that they go and strike
the following harvest season.
This is really hard for them
because the union that
Lupe Sanchez organized
did not have any strike funds, so the men
decide to go and strike, decide
to come across the border
and strike even without having funds.
The grove which they struck at was called
Arrowhead Ranch, which
was particularly owned
by the Goldwater family, so it received
a lot of media attention
and it was the first
successful strike by undocumented workers.
So when we're thinking
about what all these
what you were asking me, Steve,
about the different forms of activism,
there's legal activism, around whether
children can attend schools,
there's labor activism
that's very direct about how to organize
unauthorized workers which at the time,
had been considered to be unorganizable
and who were considered
to be the strike breakers,
oh we don't want undocumented migrants
was the common reasoning
because they will come
and they will act as strike breakers,
so it was a first instance when they said
actually, we can organize
them and we can do so
by going to Mexico and
organizing them there.
- [Steve] Any other questions?
Ana, I wanna give you the last word,
I wanna first thank you, I mean,
we need more of the
voices of more historians
thinking about these things, we're clearly
in a moment in our collective histories
in North America in which
so many of the issues
that you're talking about are certainly
in the newspaper, they're the subject
of Human Rights Watch reports,
and they're very much on our minds
as we think about the wellbeing of
our neighbors, our neighborhoods,
our family members, and as somebody
as a historian who
thinks about this period
between 1965 and 1986, and makes
what I think is a convincing argument
that so much of what
we're dealing with today,
in 2018, was framed by the period
in which, the period that you document
in this late 20th century moment,
I want just to ask you to close by saying
a word if you can about how understanding
the history from 1965 to 1986 has shaped
the way in which you
see developments today?
- Yeah, so.
In some ways we think about the history
of Mexican migration as thinking
oh they've always come, but actually,
Mexican migration,
unauthorized Mexican migration,
really starts up and
continues uninterrupted
until 2008, but it really
starts after the end
of the Bracero program.
And the reasons why it starts is because
people had been given an opportunity
to come through the Bracero program
and that was taken away, so part of what
I think is important to think about
is how the United States has historically
recruited people to come,
created a culture of migration
and then when they no longer want,
when the economy or the rhetoric
when they need a scapegoat, they decide
to close the door and blame Mexicans.
So that's one of the things
that I constantly think
about, the other thing
that I think about is
how the same stereotypes
are repeated over and over again
for example, the idea that
migrants abuse welfare.
It starts in the 1970s
because there's this idea
that there's a welfare crisis,
but it continues even up to today,
so there's just the
recycling of stereotypes.
And then there is another phenomenon
that really interests me
which is this idea that
the way populations look really change.
So as I said, up until
1986, it was primarily
men who were coming,
children were not coming,
women were not coming, that switches
and now when we think about migration,
we think about families,
we think about family
separation in the sense of deportations
but actually, we're seeing another wave
which is that since 2008, there's a net
out migration of Mexicans.
Mexicans are not coming
to the United States
when we think about these patterns,
more Mexicans are leaving than are coming
and that's extremely
important to understand
that these waves, that this notion
that there are waves of people coming
are just not true,
Mexicans are not coming,
more Mexicans are leaving and yet
it is Mexicans, even
though the populations
targeted are now primarily
Central Americans,
they are the ones whose bodies
are being targeted, but rhetorically,
it's still Mexicans, we still talk about
President Trump still talks about,
I wanna say we 'cause I'm
not talking about that,
how you know Mexicans are rapists
and criminals, so that continues
to be part of the rhetoric even though
that is no longer the reality
and now in terms of what I think
is the role of the Mexican government,
part of what historicizing has made me do
is consider the role of
the Mexican government
and I'm also extremely
interested in seeing
what the Mexican government is doing
in terms of Central
Americans who are going
through and that is what I think we need
to be talking about now, how the position
of the Mexican government
towards Central Americans
has changed, so part of what I discovered
while doing this research
was that the United States
told Mexican officials, you want Mexicans
to continue coming to the United States,
okay, then close the border
to Central Americans,
don't let Central Americans come,
'cause we're really scared
of Central Americans,
so if you stop Central
Americans from coming
we won't have to take such strong actions
at the border, which will obviously also
affect Mexicans, right,
so now we can look at
that history and say why is Mexico still
criminalizing Central Americans,
when Mexicans did get criminalized
when that didn't change
so that's part of what
I'm thinking about now.
- And it seems to me also, I mean
one of your major arguments, I guess
is that the Mexican
government had historically
sacrificed its own citizenry in a kind
of modernization project
tired to the Green Revolution
in which it sacrificed the ideals of
the Mexican revolution
to which it professed
repeatedly in the late 20th Century,
so perhaps, what you may be saying is
that it may be no surprise given
the Mexican government's failure
to live up to the terms
of the revolutionary
constitution in the late 20th century
that today, the Mexican government
may be also engaging
in a classist politics
vis a vis Central Americans,
a racist politics vis a
vis Central Americans,
a king of modernization project
tied to the United States
and a migration project
tied to the migration of the United States
that, in a sense, does gesture back
to the very period in
which you're discussing.
- That's why he was my
advisor, absolutely.
- I did not wanna give
myself the last word,
join me, though, in
thanking and applauding
Ana Minian.
(audience applauds)
Thank you, Ana.
- Thank you, everyone.
(closing music)